you need to wipe down
what's with the jeans you are live guys
alive oh whoa
welcome to your mom's house whose house
your mom yeah it is
the pilot episode of your mom's house
with your two mommies two mommies one
mic and podcast we have christina
pazsitzky you can find her at christina
comedy calm and this is my husband Tom
Segura you can find him at Tom Segura
calm road to your mom's mm-hmm and of
course we have the gentleman of the hour
hello red bad what's going on guys
what's up welcome to my studio /
cat-and-dog a poem this is dope man it's
really nice it is I'm impressed
you guys you guys live a far away for me
right led by fuck know Silver Lake
Silver Lake oh yes cool six miles it's
not bad it's not bad at all huh
yeah venial okay tada five you are we're
going to be stopping by a lot
unannounced you guys are both comics you
guys do you guys do the whole comedy on
the road together
Sonny and Cher thing or do you people
ask us that a lot and we're like I'm
comedy married duo right I feel like
that's so gay really I think I'm a
perfect storm you know oh yeah I think I
think so I think people say it sometimes
I don't know man here's the thing it's
it's a it's not like a bad idea it's
just that when you you know we're both
just trying to get the work we can get
and a lot of times you feel like hey we
want to package it then the rubbers
booking is like yeah no thanks man um
well I think with anything - because
especially as a female comic people are
like oh you're just you're fucking the
headliner and that's not you know
I mean I'd rather kind of do it - a
thing you are yeah so you guys are on
the road completely like all the time
together in separate states all the time
you guys live on like the the I Chad's
and the skypes and you just have like a
relationship or you like you know like
masturbate in front of you know webcams
or something I'm sure he would I'm too
self-conscious well we've done it a few
times yeah I must have been in front of
anybody right I figured chatroulette ah
no we just told everyone you were like
are you on that all the time okay you're
like you can't be doing that
check yeah she gave me some shit about
it yeah yeah memory I was I look at this
and then you're like so cuz I mean we'll
get it together
yes stroking their hogs so then she was
like is that what you're doing and I was
like oh no I figured cuz I don't know is
that really that bad to masturbate in
front of someone who's willing you know
what I mean is that really yeah you
don't mean if you show your face yes
show your face that's the secret you
have to always know because people are
recording you masturbating and stuff
like that
they have actually had an application on
the phone that was chat relay on the
phone on your iPhone but it only lasted
like one day but I act I got a copy of
it and no one has it like maybe only a
thousand people like those thousand
people still use it every day so you go
on you see the same five people with
their dicks out every day so you you
have that stool yeah yeah some on my
iPhone somewhere about it whether he
lasts only a day because Apple thought
oh this is you know a nice little bill
program that people can talk and meet
strangers and then some some guys do but
what the fuck you thinking having using
chat relay you can't have people
masturbating on the iPhones and yeah and
variably somebody will find a way to put
their penis on the technology and then
but my friend Patrick just taught showed
me that I didn't realize I mean I knew
it was possible but I didn't realize
that porn it caters specifically just to
the actual device the iPhone like yeah
but I mean obviously if you have the
internet you can get on board but
there's actual sites that are just
specifically designed
wirdy - absolutely so smart yeah a lot
of the main ones that like you porn and
stuff have made it so that that they
work now on the iPhone yeah stuff I just
started uh jerking it last week to my
iPhone stuff yeah and don't look I know
people are like oh is she gonna this is
so like tame for our level of discourse
with each other like we'll be laying
post coital and he'll be like I gotta
take a shit
and then that's normal for us so it did
it start off slowly though they start
off with you like leaving the bathroom
door open one time you're like oh that's
kind of weird and next thing you know
you're just taking mat so don't know did
it stuff no we don't dump in front of
each other that is the one barrier we
don't but it started Tommy you remember
we were watching television on my couch
and then it's like this like a month
into our dating and then he goes he just
grabs my hand and he puts it in his
crotch and then he farts on my hand like
are we gonna get married even then I
knew I'd ex ago and I did that blew a
fart and she's like do you want
breakfast in bed and then she blows the
fart on me and goes there's your eggs
pitch and how long did that lead she uh
yeah what was three-year relationship
good she she was the same girl that one
time I had to pee really bad and she had
to pee it really bad we both walked in
the door I only have one bathroom so the
double stacked it where she sat down and
then I put my legs around her and put my
dick in between her legs and peeped
through her legs really peed that's so
that's one of our running jokes you're
like I want to pee where you pee you
would say that to me yeah deal yeah it's
double stack and try it I've done it a
few times where she sits and you she
sits and they put your dick in between
her legs and pee facing her yeah facing
her and you pee look into each other's
eyes can you tell us what you're doing
it yeah but you have to be really drunk
to do it because I have never done it
silver have you ever done it will you
sit down to shit and with the gap it's
between your legs a girl sits in that
space and shows babe at the same time
ready no I don't I don't think I would
ever did
why that's different but yeah that's
different I guess if you have like the
explosive shit yeah you'd like hitter
you know just spray all over yeah and
they would have to well I've never seen
his his bowel movements but I hear them
through the door and they sound so
violent and explosive I'm always like
did you just have violent diarrhea and
guys that's no it was normal
yeah boys is my bathroom is on the other
side of my liquor on my bedroom so like
especially when I first meet a girl and
he go in there and was like hey I'm a
good bathroom you know she can hear
anything that's going on in it is no
good yeah so you have to turn on the
sink you have to home really loud yeah
that's a fun one other thing is another
like when you're when you first start a
we're talking I went to that hotel yeah
we started dating yeah and you're not
ready to like even like shit yeah right
knee of the person right so the thing is
you can't relax all right so all your
shits are like half shits you know and
you got like half a turd waiting inside
of you and you're like I kind of got to
go again and you look like you have shit
your bowel problems cuz you're like you
know does weird time we got a hotel one
time this is before I farted on your
Hannah yes this is very before this was
right before and I got a real nice hotel
so you're recording me yeah and I got it
like two nights so how long like 30
years ago
mmm Ellie started dating I was in and we
were aboard we have this I got a nice
room and then I realized in the morning
I was like oh I'm not ready to shed in
front of this girl yet so I would shed
in the lobby and she told me she didn't
shit all weekend I I didn't I didn't
shit for two and a half days and and
it's not that I didn't try cuz I would
be like I gotta I gotta go lobby and get
a newspaper and then you try to shit in
the lobby but you can't be gone for too
long you think well he's gonna know yeah
I tried shitting in the restaurant we
went to that tapas place really and you
remember that place we went to which one
it was some Spanish place like around
the corner and I was like from the hotel
house like I gotta pee and I went and I
Drive and I could not make it dude how'd
it go
I was fecal impaction I was fully
impacted yeah it was like I couldn't
wait for you to drop me off I was afraid
you wanted to spend the night I gotta go
yeah ran away shit and I shit a lot yeah
and the worst is even like not even
shitting it's like if you could squeeze
one out real quick so they don't know
but then you have this smell factor yeah
I remember used to always I didn't have
any kind of smelly thing so I would just
use hairspray and so she would come in
as like what the fuck it smells like
Aqua Net in here yeah
when we talk we time at a masturbation
before never and I sidetracked us on
Dookie yeah
what were you saying that you found a
new way to masturbate well I mean like I
take my laptop right everywhere and I
jerk off all the time watching stuff
online I'm saying I knew that was
possible well Wi-Fi on your my phone
yeah I didn't realize that that these
companies were Kate like they were it's
not just you can go to the site they
design stuff specifically for the iPhone
ok can I confess something yeah I've
already figured that out is on the road
I've been like I wonder if I can get
porn on my iPhone yes you can
you're dirty but you can't get the whole
footage it's like two minutes you don't
know the right places to go yeah yeah I
gotta find the new sites and you could
always take you know your DVDs and rip
them onto your iPhone - oh that's
interesting
that's interesting right bad news you
know what's so funny which side are you
using am i telling no I'm straight you
born no strictly black and Puerto Rican
gang bang shelter dogs calm just can't
do anything bragging what are we gonna
gang rings as when the worst nightmare
anything no but uh where's nightmare
getting gangbanged by all black guy
nooooo Rican guys that's my fantasy Oh
get out of here I want to see I wanna
walk and watch the fucking the Lakers
just line up on the Lakers just go to
town wearing timberlands and socks and
that's it and golden socks like Justin
Slayer and the PI players cross Jesus
well yeah she knows the my name
well I'm I'm a student of the world Tom
I'm a woman of many interests it's great
that you guys can talk about this so
openly to millions of people oh god I
forgot about that yeah we were playing
this game lately I want if you ever
played this game with a girl you're
dating and that is to kind of you find
different ways to you know keep it
exciting and somewhat try to like is
that what that is
horrify each other in it in a new way so
the thing was on our iPhones against is
like an iPhone commercial that we're
doing it right actually but you have
like your home your home image right
right what you have so the other day I I
log I pick up my phone and the image is
an old woman's gaping vagina like it's
it's it looks like a like a grenade when
often and like it's hanging right open
that's so weird she what set it as my
house could lock my friend
yeah but then revenge is fun because
then I laid in bed later that night and
I looked at my phone and guess who was
there it was a Dolf Hitler smiling and
courting other women that's normal right
have a picture of Hitler I hear
definitely definitely isn't what
everybody has no no I know I my
practical jokes seem a little bit more
not as a pornographic or I do I do
fucked up shit yeah I do
like changing phone numbers of contacts
and their phone also like night I can
stave your mom it ends up to being like
Planned Parenthood or something
really good take the ex-boyfriend or
ex-girlfriend and make it you know
somebody else and really yeah especially
it's good for texting too
you know you're trying to text somebody
and you're actually texting your
ex-boyfriend or ex-girlfriend what I do
is do you do is when things are going
well no absolutely
now I like to throw wrenches into missus
into that already pretty bad yeah that's
really like um that's a deviant
scandalous yeah I'm not totally awake it
either right that's what I'm a half a
Starbucks right now
cheers Cheers did you want a glass of
water there yeah look zero or someone
yeah a Bud Light with lime
have you heard that's really clever and
kind of evil yeah then it is another
thing you could do is I you could do
locate your iPhone now on your iPhone
for free so you don't need the MobileMe
app anymore just as of two days ago so
another thing you can do especially if
if you guys have like a family plan
together I guess something like that but
another thing kid is like if you're like
where's Tom I'm at he's not answering
his phone
let me just go on my phone oh here's GPS
locations to exactly where you're at
right now
oh I don't know if I could do that yeah
I think that's such a violation the way
really seems like it is the honestly
weak you know where I am oh there's no
like you don't know where I'm at like
you always Norman right obviously if you
cheat into your phone is so easily and
there's no problems here yeah but
there's still that unspoken fear that
every woman has of like what if I come
home early and he's like paying somebody
or what if I look for his his iPhone and
he's somewhere else like there's just
that that paranoia I guess that fear
that's always in girls I bang chicks
like I'm a bang chicks are coming home
early so down no I mean do you have that
fear Tommy like what if I come home
early and Christine is like banging
someone else hmm no never you sure dude
yeah hello yeah what if you should have
that thought all the time
no I come here only she's banging
someone else no do you get that Brian uh
I was paired up here with you yeah that
make I mean I feel bad for Tom all the
time we always talk about it you know
because of my type
yeah sending tag text messaging is same
technology for relationships it's just
crazy wait as you you you would think
that when you you're like I'm gonna come
home early what if she's with somebody
else yeah yeah I think all right I
always think about Christina with other
people what kind of men specific mostly
black or Mexican blurry yeah in the
green yeah Porto Ricans oh yeah
definitely higher in the list Tommy
thinks I'm in love with Puerto Ricans
that have the thin beards like the daddy
yankee so she likes that's what I like
it's funny like the ones that hang out
at the barber shop every day to give
clean you up you'll pick me up I blow
that man it the crazy thing to about
relationships with technology is net
nowadays like you know when back in the
day it's like were you at I'm at my
friend's house watching TV chill the
fuck out now with FaceTime you just like
I really turn on your face time I want
to say exactly well I'm not on my wife I
never will get over here right now gotta
have my Donuts oh gee I get I don't know
I think it's you it's so much easier to
feel slighted now because of technology
like if you text message someone and
they don't answer you back immediately
you do and then you see that they're on
Twitter tweeting something retarded yeah
you're like oh I know that fucker just
saw what I texted him cuz he's on yeah
you could like match up timelines now a
Twitter Facebook and then you're like
you could check Twitter like oh she
she'd she posted this from a web that
means she is home well everyone's
becoming stalkers not by choice but just
because it's of the information is now
available to be us like soccer or
whatever yeah I don't want to know that
much but you do yeah don't mind the car
I am I put you together like that for
you all the time I always watch your do
you do not I do you what are you talking
about have you really yeah absolutely I
look at like like I'll text and then
I'll look at your timeline will be like
this bitch is not paying attention right
now do you guys do the Foursquare thing
or the check-in things i what's that
it's like the thing that
or people you see a lot of times on like
Facebook just implemented it on their
own website where you're like hey I'm at
the Cheesecake Factory and a terrible
why do people do that she would anybody
I don't want anybody knowing where I am
ever or died did not at home or you know
it's just stupid this is stories like
where people will post on Facebook hey
we're going out and then people get
robbed that way yeah absolutely
dumb but the I understand like I mean I
guess everybody has their own whatever
gives them a sense of accomplishment but
when people are like and and now the
mayor of the movie theater in your life
so what man having governor of the Olive
Garden birthday like that really know
that gets you excited but you're the
game's been the fucking the whole garden
the most right in a sewer bragging that
you like off there but I do use Yelp a
lot when we travel just to see where to
look yeah if you're in some shit town
you're like I don't know where to get
like a slice of pizza that helped but
can I tell you my biggest pet peeve
about Facebook is people that update
stuff on what their kids are doing yeah
and you're like really dude I don't
really I don't care that your five year
old took a nap today like good for you
or it's the work and my my relationship
with my sister is just now her everyday
sending me new videos of my nephew which
is great I love my nephew and everything
but that's all she does non-stop photos
and videos I get it it's he's a baby
yeah you know you're like what are you
up to like I'm videotaping anyway yeah
what happened do anything else I change
him I guess I guess the other mommy
brain takes over and people like knows
their mind it's not there yet what yeah
I understand I guess no let's try right
now let's try it on the podcast yeah Tom
God do a double stack and we we have
such a huge hit on our hands
yeah we conceived on the first podcast
so you think oh absolutely absolutely
that's not a bad idea
well just started off slow and see it's
only been a couple of weekends here to
loosen you up a little bit now you're
talking
now you're talking language it's the
first good idea you've had all day do
you guys ever did the filming of your of
your sex for your personal enjoyment
see ourselves naked right every done it
I've done it a few times well both would
always with them knowing it but it never
turns out good it never looks good I'm
always supposed to delete it and then
after I you know undelete it when she's
not looking
no rename the file but here's a tip
though if you really want to hide your
personal video and you know she's going
to go through your computer you could
always like right-click a program so if
it's like sex dot MOV just move it to
sex dot jpg and it won't come up as a
jpg and it won't work as a movie when
you click on it but you know exactly
what that sex JPEG is that's so sneaky
just make you dog a mistake a dog sneaky
number two I really am fascinated by his
uh his idea of when things are going
yeah I just sabotage the doesn't make it
worse I do you know it's you know it's
not gonna get better if it's going
downhill it's just gonna continue though
you could go down here you know
somebody's well just make it to them fun
advanced texting her mom when she's
texting her so you think she's taking
her ex-boyfriend right so oh my god you
don't feel bad you everybody gets all
look at a smile yeah you love it it's
excited about it yeah there's a lot of
things you can do with that to fuck up a
relationship he's a clever boy it sounds
like you've got a lot of experience yeah
that way so how long you guys been
together complete like a when did you
guys meet like a long time ago are you
guys just like fresh mutton oh like end
of o2 o4 o 3g me doubt economy probably
met do you remember
yeah i met the cat club yeah that's on
set yeah that it was a they had the
saturday night comedy show there and
tommy was like 23 I'm three years older
I'm 26 and wow he's so good yeah yeah
totally he was so cute and he was so
quiet and he was like the only comedian
that never tried to come on to me or be
skeevy and he just treated me like a
like a person can I know yeah as much as
he's capable of and a
he's so cute we met at the cat club and
then I had a room at Tangier and Los
Feliz now a book him what like every
week nice he's here so funny she was
dating somebody else
ah I was dating a Chinese guy back what
I know why you're so nice to you guys
like this goes broken but I still get
ridiculed for that PS from Tom I was
plugging a lot of those back though it's
not like did you guys have the weird
comedy relationship seat like I never
only did one comic and when I started
dating or like all my personality traits
that would use on a normal non comedian
woman just trying to be like a little
jokey here and there you know a little
slaw like happy personality she'd be
like you need to rewrite that like no
you know no dissection of my personality
where I just was like all right I can't
be this happy nice guy and you want to
feel like I'm on stage when I'm done
right but yeah that's terrible
I don't think we're like that I think
we're I think we're a lot freer with
each other because we're comedians like
I think it's our part we're so close to
each other and we can say what we want
to
I couldn't imagine dating a civilian now
because you can't say awful things to
them and have them not be offended but
we say awful things to each other
constantly but it's fun yeah like it's
all funny but do you ever like say
something I mean you're like that's
hilarious and you both like this I want
this joke no I like this doing it like a
joke battle to the death
no it's more like if she says something
it's like hilarious I'll be like that
really like she won't realize that you
should you know ever started one realize
like oh yeah then so of like sometimes
she'll say something I'll be like that's
really funny
you don't it's now you know initially oh
really like yeah you need to write that
down
well I think - cos where I'm growing
your boy that are acts aren't gonna be
that similar yeah so like if he said
something that smells like I'm bleeding
I'm bleeding
oh my
perience yeah brah can't you can't tell
period jokes like I do yeah you had said
something today that was inappropriate
funny it made me laugh erotic you said a
Bud Light Lime that's not even for
people that's for Mexicans oh yeah
that's them no our folks is gonna bring
it over tomorrow that's why it tastes
like Bud Light with line that's pretty
much all but is that supposed to be good
I don't think I think you know with like
any beer there's a lot of people that
believe if you just put a little lime in
it a little lemon it makes up you know
but that's my corona it's for like
Mexico cloners yeah I don't like beer
you for Lyman a Bud Light yeah it's
awful not for people it's from Mexico
like the vile and this not even for
people Mexicans
yeah I love Mexicans don't you realize
how insulting other things I grew up in
Los Angeles I'm an Angeleno I love the
Mexican people I think it's an insult to
Mexicans Bud Light Lime have you ever
loved a Mexican um you know what okay
here's a problem there we go
okay go excite grew up in LA a lot a lot
of mexicanos love the blondes so I got
harassed a lot by Mexican boys a lot of
Mexican girlfriends never a Mexican
boyfriend they were too short they're
always too short
yeah hate song she's a double if you
read them so I like Puerto Ricans that
was my flavor because they're exotic we
don't have the Minnelli
there's not a lot of Puerto Ricans in
the world yeah but aren't for Reagans is
Mexican with longer hair I like them
well Tommy what was your flavor before
you were married mmm just gotta have it
I didn't really you know blood pudding I
thought yeah well you've been with two
Indian women like night night right not
like my Native American but two Indian
women like full-on Indian woman's sure
yeah so was that like a thing that you
just did once in a while or is that like
a real
that you you look for it we just kind of
fell into my lap oh so to speak the
Indian girls
yeah the rural Indian the real India
Hammond I'm sorry Slumdog Millionaire
Indian yeah well now yes
some dogs where did you where did you
meet these Indian women Seattle when
Rogers yeah I guess when we start dating
what's the year before that
Virginians I remember he told me they
have really dry elbows and hands and it
always bugged oh yeah like a she
actually then really crunchy nails
that's you know I have three of three
Indian stepsisters what a coincidence
well I don't think it is a coincidence
it's really weird you don't really bring
them over enough hmm
they're not a she I know but they could
be if we dry them out did you really
make lugs Andean woman at the same time
too serious what why how come I didn't
hear about this is the first time I
boarded us I'm sorry I didn't I didn't
know different not for me and learning
divorce ah it was the one yesterday Utah
you told me you didn't know you went to
Argentina secretly yeah you didn't yes
we were hanging up pictures in our house
he goes all I got that from Argentina
when I was there with my lover in 1992
it might be 92 Lily you were 12
um I just I like Europeans chicks that
was kind of my style I had different
I've had German chicks really yeah he
talks about this one bride that he
banged in Africa wants like Africa yeah
with her I don't love with her but I
remember I blew a load nur and I got
really nervous right cuz aids or yeah
well she was like she was a junkie she
was reformed junkie Mike and she was
like in a punk band she was all tatted
up and she was like alright and then
after I was done I was like that
probably isn't a good person did not
wear protection with oh it's you were in
Africa right right right yeah I think I
think I would wear a condom on the
airplane before
I know I started to kind of have a panic
attack
yeah and I was like kind of freaking out
and she saw that I was freaking out and
she had this I don't know some pill she
was like this is good for your stomach
cuz I was like a morning-after pill
I took it and then then I did it again
oh my god Tommy
you know to try to get to try to get to
you've been tested for AIDS yeah I hope
so it's just like they said it's like
slight positive but not yeah I always
make the girl get the aid stairs and
then like up I'm fine
we can't can we be real can we have real
talk here yeah this is real first of all
you better have my doughnut first of all
do you know anybody that has HIV AIDS
yeah like a straight person I don't want
to say like don't say no yeah somebody
like a straight person not straight no I
don't think I think it's pretty
impossible for a straight person are
really good eat and I hate to sound like
hey everybody go out and just have I'm
sure there are realest sex but I feel
like I've never met anybody who's
straight personally in my life no
doesn't mean doesn't exist but we can
get it straight people can get it
they're really into the butthole yeah oh
yeah you know by the way I recently had
butthole sex again yeah like I called it
off completely was he uh big I don't
know he's like no no he plays basketball
I don't know but I liked when I last had
it I was like I'm never doing this again
this it smells it was you know is just
an awful experience they were laughing
but the time before and I was like I
thought the recent time no no this is
like three years ago and I'm never doing
this again right and then so then when I
had it last it was like kind of like why
am I doing this I'm Denise Bennett was
great yeah wait sorry
so we're condom uh how is that possible
goodbye the same with buttholes it's
supposed to be so much more dangerous
right now
there's blood third why you can't miss
your ring oh that's right that's why
it's more likely to get through the anus
yeah it's actually just like tiny little
tears no no yeah
this guy he's never had butts before did
you put lube in his answer on AF flesh
live yeah it's funny because I know my
dad either progress with daily response
about a fleshlight and so sent us a
bunch of flesh lube which is just like
this water-based Lube and one is just
water syllable and the other one is like
caught fire or some way that's good
first night I didn't know but that makes
your dick for like it's on fire how
would anybody like that isn't is it good
no it's awful sounds off I have a
question yes the fleshlight so you b'gok
inside overjoyed show you what yeah okay
I don't want to touch it down next it's
never been used before
oh oh I see alien one it looks like soap
like really pretty shiny yeah that's it
that's the alien so that people can see
I know but we've seen it so horrifying
have you put your penis no no no anyone
put their meanings no no you put your
finger in it does you could feel how
realistic it is I actually put my penis
throw it wait wait I want to look at the
vagina so when you B bum so yellow your
bogachan there low and we'll see there's
on the bottom it unscrews that you could
have at while you're fucking it if you
add a little bit of air to it it gets
less suction or more suction and then
when you come in it the bottoms unscrews
it off like it like a spit valve like a
trumpet and then yeah you just put the
faucet on the top and blow it out the
bottom or the whole thing pulls out so
it's like this huge that is amazing and
I'm surprised the men haven't invented
this like a hundred years ago they did
it show I got touch it I did I tied you
from you're in the middle of it though
yeah that's the best part is this
one-of-a-kind it feels like I mean you
know what well no but I'm saying I'm not
touch anyone else's vagina only my own
is diffent when you touch your own
that's what most girls whoa I'm thinking
I see it yeah now imagine a little bit
of hot Lube in there that's real the
Sunday more do you use yours what I've
used that one a lot
oh man didn't believe you you're joking
you would do that to it look in the
bottom I only think I cleaned it out
there is crust around it look
oh I'm put in my lap I smell it oh so I
can't leave you keep this in the living
room why not this is where I do most of
my masturbation I didn't really do that
thank you
Oh girls we've used one before yes I'll
show you when to see the one I actually
wanna know is it blue no but it's it
it's pretty funny how I never mind I
mean is it pretty awesome to jerk off
for us it's definitely better than your
hand because it feels you know your hand
like like Joey says it so it's connected
your body so there's a part of your
brain that you're like all right I'm
touching myself yeah this actually feels
like a third parties that you know can
Merry Christmas how much are these maybe
tell me we'll get one like we can get
you one we can get you one I want you to
take it didn't sure where to give you
one I know he has not please take it
with you yeah we can we talk about anal
yeah I am so phobic of my anus being
prodded blown out I am self annual rate
of it yeah because my mother worked for
a doctor growing up and she said that
she used to regale me with these awful
tales of men who would go to the
emergency room because they would have
foreign objects stuck in there and their
bum cakes right and how that does like
irreparable damage to your butthole
that's what that's what I always stop at
I don't have to worry about the money
these girls in 20 years when they're
pooping themselves yeah but dot doesn't
the Dozen the poop come out faster you
like what you're doing I'm saying like
when you're doing it see I think the
thing is it's like if you have one on
deck than it is but if that girl has
gone recently and doesn't have one deck
you know I think I think it's fine
because like the one before she had it
on deck obviously you know because when
I it smelled like it when I pulled it
out and just like I'm never doing this
again but the last time was like it felt
just like a second vagina really I heard
that it doesn't I heard that it's a
little initially tight and then it's
like this expansive area because it's
your intestines or whatever
I don't know I mean I think it's also
involving hit like if the girl is
although she has like the hemorrhoid so
it's a little bit different you know but
if it's she's a younger girl with no
hemorrhoids yet then you're giving her
the hemorrhoid so it's yet you know
that's pretty hard
Tommy to me and we're done you know I'm
not gonna lie I've tried a few times and
I've never been successful never I was
very young when I tried well and I don't
think I would approach it differently
today and with you it's definitely
violent no I'm not violent it's a
process it's been brought up and it's
like eelinator like yeah mobile I got a
ten year anniversary and you're like oh
yeah you fucked me faggot you should
call me Davis
that's how we do it I saw him names
yeah fucking queer yeah she got always
does it grab him or like a passionate
moment she's like yeah you're like a
faggot you know they're you know what's
funny is my mother married an Indian guy
like a Slumdog why should I give you to
two of them
yeah what a coincidence it's wonderful
and she used to chastise him all the
time and call him a faggot and a
towelhead and it was just in our family
was like a joking and and you know he
would call her like gypsy tits and all I
could mine garyun and then I thought
that's what you're supposed to do so the
chaste that is your husband oh shit on
the fag and stuff she doesn't who feels
normal
doesn't call me that I don't I know no
awful after not during you better have
my doll nuts keeps with the guy by the
way if you just Delonte West but if you
are gonna be listening to this podcast a
lot you're gonna get a lot of dirty talk
yeah you're gonna get a lot of lack
should be too oh boy there's a lot of
racism a lot irate were very racist
white eccentric gay shit
not a gay talk shit talk sex talk
mmm-hmm this the main the best were the
best thing wait who's the guy that was
like we got a rapist up in here oh that
was an toybox hide your wife I
dude I went with Joe Rogan to the
d-stroid date walk last weekend we did a
couple shows and then UFC 123 and the
day before when they have the weigh-ins
we went to the the palace at Auburn
Hills for the weigh-ins and you know in
sideways alignment like Daymond for the
Wayans brothers we went to see Shawn and
Marlon loans and the hood and Joe was
like there's no way I'm missing this and
I was like can I please come and he was
like yes we have to see the Wayans
brothers they're so they're so talented
we get there and he's you know he's like
you know running the show introducing
the fibrils and and and I'm behind the
the curtain you know we're back where
the fibers are and I see this um really
tall sort of odd-looking black woman
long hair she's like six - and I'm like
oh like she's tall her face is kind of
beat like she's what broke looking in
the face but like you know but you still
tap it I'd still tag it cuz she's like
she's like six - right now there's yeah
there's nothing right yeah something I
like to get down with brown so I'm like
I'm like I do that shit I'd break it in
half so oh no that's him like face is
kind of fucked up but like whatever
she's cute and then I kind of remind my
phone I'm just waiting around and Joe's
doing his thing and I see Joe talking to
this woman and then I seen with his
phone and he's talking to her and then
as we're leaving we're finally leaving
we're done with the lanes we're going to
go do the shows he he goes uh you could
run tell that homeboy and I and like he
just says it and I just laugh and I'm
like yeah I just laugh cuz I think he's
just quoting it he's like yeah I got
that video um and I was like of what he
was like with Antoine and I was like
what do you mean are you serious yeah
told me that
he's like units doesn't want us there
and I was like he's great no he's like
that fucking super tall dude that black
guy I was like I thought there's a woman
he's pretty cool a effeminate can you
see it on Joe's on YouTube it's on his
site
I didn't know that yet so he he talked
to him and I I was blown away that it
was a man but he was at Wow
the the photo Joe's got a really funny
video hi it's on his YouTube that I
don't know how yes that is great he um
he'd talked him it was Ben I couldn't
believe it
speaking of black people not to deter do
you want to discuss the documentary we
watched the other night
Titan the Diary of a tire black man what
angry black man you seen this no wait
why were you guys watching this notice
you're like laying around naked Ellen
here's the thing we were yet I was like
I got a shit and then choose it let's
watch this movie yes well it was a good
documentary that this man he my parent
Lee was very upset with black women and
how they treat black men and it was all
about how angry black women are and
stuff but I kind of didn't like it they
didn't the men don't take responsibility
it was all like I'm a woman yeah I mean
we should set the set up the fact that
damn don't know art on the podcast it's
so unprofessional
babe we've traveled together just
meeting everybody right I apologize
that's a listener to apologize do any
hairspray huh let me get the aqua knock
winner so disgusting there's nothing
wrong I'm a lady
house I'll see my bag associate my BAE
Oh another one
is that a kitty oh is a you know that
was I thought that was you know that
what I mean look at kitty thank you no
it's too cute what more than that sorry
so continue so let's talk about it okay
so we're we're kind of obsessed with
black culture yes like the most the way
I think
curious Americans are too it's not like
no we love black people
that we're intrigued because there are
so many things white people don't know
about black culture like I watched a
documentary called good hair you see
that Chris Rock's documentary I had no
idea that like black woman's hair was
such a political issue you know cuz like
it's the whole do you get extensions
versus letting your nappy row and
extensions are expensive and then you
get your black boyfriend to pay for them
well it's true it's a personal judgement
mazing it's really interesting it's
pretty amazing how many movies black
eyes and black people will put out about
hair too honest it's a big deal because
do you you know conform to what the
white man wants you to have straight
that I didn't have to push it just kind
of that kind of fell out oh it's so loud
Tom and it's louder I'm sorry guys um
human like who knew they could rap
there's always things that you don't
know I didn't know but this the
documentary angry diary Oh an angry
black man diarrhea some awesome that
maybe it's just an angry
Turkey he says every time it comes out
that homeboy no but it's really
interesting that basically it's so
prevalent in black culture that there
was there was enough there that this guy
made this documentary where he went
around and interviewed basically both
black men and black women and it kind of
validated in a way his perspective which
was are there just a bunch of angry
black women out there who are just angry
all the time and give grief to men to
black men and tell them that they're no
good and there was a host of people both
men and women that said yes that is true
and then he explored why is that the
case that's basically why was it the
case well I mean there was it was kind
of complicated it's very complicated
but um it couldn't be because why in a
black woman before I know unfortunately
not that's still my bucket list though
you once I want a nice pretty one now
don't know am I going to get you know in
you but that's definitely on my list why
not this one no I'm not what I do that I
just want to tell that now boy now Tom
said haven't you I'm sure I've been
dated learnt so much about each other
today on this podcast I mean I blew a
few out yeah yeah it was way before you
see I'm on the constant search for the
biggest areola or nipple size and
usually real ladies have the the biggest
so the pepperonis Bologna's and that's
the only reason I want to do it is to
see if that theory is correct cuz then I
might be in love you know you will like
the woman oh that's all I want
really if I could have boob all it
nipple that would be the do you like to
like lick it and play with it I just
like the look of it
very cool-looking you know it's mostly
it you owe me man what you give that now
I mean they're the cool and everything
don't buy just like a look at that see
that that's yeah yes aren't work yes
dependent yeah that's the biggest nipple
size that you can run yeah you know
what's your background what are you nice
look what Oh like yeah um German Irish
well is that what you were asking
I mean yeah yeah my backer huh yeah
that's what she was asking I need to
know before I can talk to people yeah
really well say did you ever get like a
no I have not
I've you know why I think it's because I
don't I don't know how to talk to black
dudes because they always said to you
with like crazy game and I'm always like
I don't know I don't know like I'm very
awkward I can't the answer we had not
anymore it's not longer but sorry I mean
if someone was worried does preposition
propositions proposition would say
preposition proposition uh you know I
mean I'm be willing to explore that yeah
the easiest way to talk is just to take
the last letter of every word off when
you talk to him
oh what's that yeah that's the easiest
way to fit in that's what I've learned
okay so yeah I've just never never I
just never happened yet regrettably yeah
may be true tomorrow will bring
shadow have you ever thought about
bringing somebody into the bedroom as a
couple yes hmm I don't recommend that by
one who really did it ruins
relationships I've had two threesomes
and both of them ruin a relationship
like Davis about days after one was the
next day it was bad what happens like
well first of all wait can we set this
up yeah how long were you date this to
go to the first time first one was in
high school I dated her for two and a
half years
so you are already dating like two and a
half year and a half years and she was
our boss we worked at a movie theater
and she was our boss and we were like 17
18 and she was like 24 and we decided to
like at least let me guess nothing guy
no you're all hanging out because we got
off work and we were drinking and the
other girl's house or a basement she
looketh her mom just 24 but she was you
know a movie theater manager so that's
understandable but uh she had like a keg
leftover from her mom had like a party
so we were all just in the basement
drinking I went to the bathroom came
downstairs and they were undressing each
other I was like whoa what the fuck's
going on here they're like you want to
join us and next thing I know my
girlfriend was laying on top of the
other girl naked just totally grinding
going at it
craziness and I remember having my back
to it doing woman oh my god oh my god oh
my god like I was like yeah easy yeah we
did it with everything that was the
first time I ever had a sex with a girl
cuz the other girl that my girlfriend
sigtuna lot she she wants to do is oh my
god okay so I as six with this girl and
I remembered having sex with this girl
was like wow this is crazy I look over
at my girlfriend she's just sitting
there masturbating watching us really
yeah like this is awesome
and so then uh we all went to sleep and
the next morning her mom came down the
baseman's like hey I cooked you guys
breakfast I remember just being
completely naked with her daughter and
my girlfriend on the other side and the
daughter died jumps up and gets dressed
and goes upstairs and me my girlfriend
is putting on her clothes and my
government started crying just
immediately so God look what the fuck
happened what are we doing and then it
like two days later she you know we
broke up but wow that's a lot that's a
lot to do
that's your first anal first and Angie's
first threesome and your underage sex
weight you know who can school that's
like Oh what how troubled are those two
girls like how one girl
nowadays I believe as a lesbian and the
other girls a cop now Wow yes right yeah
because I don't think that I would have
the wherewithal lesbian at school I
don't probably you know at all right
that's pretty advanced how about your
second time second time I dated a girl
that was a hippie a Grateful Dead always
like that and she was like the other
hippie girl that like lived in a car
that would crash on her couch and smoke
weed with us all the time in Sherman and
one time we dis all had sex and then
after that they started like kind of
hooking up more than I hooked up with
her well and then she one of them gave
me crabs and then I Jesus so you've made
so they became lesbians - yeah well like
you're a conduit to briefly they were
but not lesbians now like when I was
like three kids and the other one has
two kids and they're both married or
something like that Wow did um Jim know
I was saying like I think I'm more
uptight about like I would not have the
wherewithal in high school to be like
hey guys what do you say we do and even
in college I was not that but were you
ever attracted to look at some most
girls seem like they're attracted to
other girls like I would get it once did
you have that in you but yeah I think
other women are super pretty and I I
think I'm too afraid to go through its
down like I just don't nice I'm too
afraid like I'm too awkward I'm not
comfortable I'm you know I can tell
jokes to a roomful of strangers and talk
about other shit but for some reason in
private life like that's not we're gonna
it's not gonna there's a lot of time
yeah could you imagine baby we had
someone else I would be so general with
an Asian if you don't go with Asian
cause I know Asian kurtal
go with Asian girl a young asian girl
you know folks Jack and cokes no I mean
like 20 couple day you would not be down
only shaved what you would not be down
you I would be so insecure and so
worried that you would fall in love with
her I don't think I can go through with
it make and blindfolded the whole time
and
this this this that's right I gotta cool
and what would you would you be okay to
the Tommy know you I would not recommend
it yeah well what is it doesn't mean I'm
what does it feel like emotionally isn't
it very like it feels like your your
partner's cheating on you like that
movie with the girl that had the first
one with the odelay the whole time like
I felt it too
like I'm like my god she was fucking
somebody else you know even though as a
girl it was and even though I fucked her
too it was just like this is fucked up
she's cheating on me kind of mm-hmm
you're traumatized I think I don't know
I don't know maybe when we're at the end
like stale and crusty because I feel
like that's what people do when we make
the last step of your highway of your
relationship you're like let's have a
three-way that's just rude
yeah that's this to end it right that's
what I'm saying like that's the final
nail in the coffin is that's the
three-way all right
yeah yeah so counter-productive
maybe we should make a resonant maybe
the bad moves only three oh yes yeah
swing your paw one for each person maybe
we need to doing it one boy one girl
comedians only which comedians in our
aura G inner last nail in the college a
mouthy may Jay London and then the girls
would be
Aaron Ellen DeGeneres Kelly Kirsten
kelly Kirsten uh-oh whoa what about um
Monique Ellie are you Janet oh man yeah
yeah she's very funny yeah like how you
pronounced it Monique like it's exotic
yeah but I have my dollar notes what
yeah what what Tom seems upset that
we're talking about having her threesome
he's just like mad mad upset
seriously he's a grizzly bear you guys
have another chatter no no no might be
upset you seem disappointed that I that
I'm not able to thank you is this a joke
I mean yeah I kind of fight you ready
come around by this point yeah so yeah
so disappointing it is kind of would you
do it again the threesome Brian
uh no if it was a girl that I just was
having sex with not dating or something
sure I would do it but it's just not
something that it is Ricky yeah dr. Guha
says it's bad too plus I've gotten to
this point where I'm 36 where I'm kind
of done being like that you know it's
just like I don't know windows in 36 no
I got about four years they have to you
know 1036 at all now you really look
younger too that's cuz I smoke I tan you
Jim yeah I do all that shit
tl to do to be tanning though is more of
a relaxing thing you know I don't do it
every day every week or anything like
but once in a while I'm just like I need
to just lay down and get some sundry
what they made a little on yeah I did
yeah oh yeah did you get recently you
look here I know I just got back from
West Hollywood mmm
yeah I did I do it under stressful
situations I've been stressed out oh
yeah I've been wrist wrestling really
what's going on not just relationships
shit yeah but um you're doing stand-up
tattoo yeah exactly
he says Emma that's great
congratulations I did I in Austin open
up all five shows yeah yeah how'd it go
it's it's good but you know the problem
is is that you go from like an open mic
with like five people then you get
thrown in front of like 700 people it's
completely different yeah and some jokes
that you don't know work or not you
can't tell when you're doing it in front
of you know other comics and a fucking
coffee house but so then actually going
in front of people you didn't realize
all right that jokes an awesome joke
that joke sucked why do I even do that
joke you know so it's kind of hard to
even be a comic when you're put in that
situation yeah yeah but is that those
that but that's what the like what
happens is when you do like you do those
open mics well then you kind of realize
I need more real audience you don't need
the three and four people but you need
to start doing like the 30 people yeah
yep it's like it's because what that
actually does provide a pretty real
gauge right like you'll find it like you
can do and you can tell you could tells
you can do the 300 person shows and then
do those jokes in front of 30 and 40
people right and the joke that kills in
front of those three 400 people right
we'll make the thirty people it will
crush you like oh that's just that
that's a good joke right just is it's a
well like it works the same way but you
need that the non-comic just crowd which
is like you know there's enough this
room like that you just have to yeah I
think open mics kind of there they're
not good gauges for what's I could for
anything the good food meaning like the
out-of-work actresses that are truly in
a comedy and then you could like do good
in front of them maybe like impress them
and then no you know what over my
threesome is worth over good morning
it's like building that fuck you
attitude that you kind of need to have
we were like I'm gonna fucking do this
set I don't care what you guys think and
that helps but other than that you know
the most annoying thing is what these
open mic errs are like last night this
guy
like you know he just from moved from
Chicago and blah blah blah and this
guy's you know just doing all these bits
and then I'm realizing that he's just
fucking copying it like he stole all his
jokes like one of his bits was like I
met this girl last and I had to put my
hat in she she was so horny that I put
my hand down her pants and it felt like
I was feeding a horse and I'm like well
are you really doing this really they're
like he just moved here from Chicago
yeah and he just had like this this
attitude where he was just like he
thought he was the shit and then I just
wanted to be dude you're fucking doing
old hacky joke it's a joke joke so trees
oh yeah well you know what I realized
though the more you do comedy like those
open mics are just so miserable and the
comedians are so miserable but the more
successful like you become and the
people that you're around the nicer they
get oh yeah and the cooler they get you
notice the guys that are really
successful a lot of times are also
really cool it's the it's once you're
starting out you're so insecure right
and you're just so hungry to do anything
yeah people become animals in that state
yeah I think it's like it's so hard
though dude to get through that that
open mic part because the worst part is
is like you're spending what two hours
to do three to five minutes
you know like sitting waiting we're
driving go it's awful signing up for a
list not gonna list the reverse to is
that um hope when you go you know
sometimes you're like I know this is
funny like you'll you'll have like a new
thing you like I know that this is funny
alright you get up there and you get
like like a shit reaction from the crowd
and we're like it's almost makes you go
you don't go maybe this isn't funny you
go fuck these people like yeah you know
I mean like you were like I know this
would work right like that's the worst
day because then you have to keep on
like there's a bit like that I was doing
recently that was just like that and
every time I did it I got the same
shitty reaction but it was also in front
of the same shitty people
No what was that open like last night
that new south south or the middle it
just opened up on Melrose they're having
an open mic every day now lock on and
then Tuesdays at 8 o'clock but that's
one of the few clubs in Los Angeles like
New York if you want to open like in New
York you have like six different places
you can go to you know hit the train and
do that six open mics a night for others
so doing regular shows ourselves I think
what he just bought it so he just has
like a small stage right now the next
three months he's gonna be opening up to
bigger stages in this place is open
might work just like a regular just sign
up yes sign up sheet every day five
minutes and he his discounts on shiver'd
comics did you ever do it was open mic
in Culver City it was this guy that ran
a bar it was called his name was Beano
and he would hear an open mic seven
nights a week just because he loved
stand-ups and you could go and it would
just be a room full of angry black
people but it would be like but it was
the best because if you did well you
really did well and you knew that your
shit was on point and if you bombed you
ate a dick and they let you know that
you were not funny but I would go there
a lot like back in the day just
miserable sections mostly for the second
anyways she went to these days fine they
had free Rob three-way Tuesdays
three-way Tuesday that's silly
um op Corinne oh and they have free
popcorn morose Thanksgiving yeah what do
you get are you guys having the old
Thanksgiving romantic thing you guys
going out to eat is raising each other
you're doing it with the family my pops
man yeah one of my dad
really lean pocket broccoli cheese no
are you doing yeah this is actually the
first Thanksgiving single said it kind
of blows but now I'm just gonna friend's
house they they easy go to every year
with their family and you know the road
will this was like you wanna come in
pink ignored I'm not that's that thanks
lagging but that's alright that's okay
really good yeah traditional style
additional yeah my dad's dating the
street he's brought and he's like oh she
wants to go yeah he's 64 any days like
20 year-olds but this one's like 30
something we're gonna light an Indian on
fire you're gonna come for that part
we're gonna eat today well yeah but then
we eat them you know mmm red chicken red
chicken that's right spicy red chicken
with we do a traditional style though
dude then as we as we cut into him we go
21 and then we take a bite I'm more
excited about Black Friday this is you
guys ever do - it's a Black Friday where
are you ok you really you know your shit
right is there something that you're
looking forward to just technologically
savvy right or a general Black Friday
well Black Friday this year it seems
like everybody's just selling Nintendo
wheeze because Nintendo is doing so bad
so like every single that's the big
thing like we have a Nintendo Wii with
two free games it's nothing really sure
this only for like really - $1.99 with
two free games and then some places are
like $1.99 with the $25 gift card I was
thinking of getting a ps3 I will you
have an Xbox yet I have the old xbox and
I threw it out icing on the 360 I mean I
do want it for the blu-ray player
all right then yeah get the new ps3 is
pretty sweet good for the blu-ray it's a
blu-ray player as well so yeah but who
has blu-ray discs anymore and do we
anymore anymore blu-ray discs they still
make them sorry still myself I'm a
laserdisc sir yeah I don't know blue
Rollie this is the new one THD ask like
the height like that like this isn't an
8-track okay freedom I listen to vinyl I
only listen to records
oh fuck him no i didn't i thought i
thought blu-rays was those old lazy days
like the idea had in my head sorry it's
been a while I highly recommend you give
me a TV because there's a lot of good TV
deals yes we didn't buy a TV
I think Walmart has a TV deal like a 47
inch or 50 inch for something like $4.99
that's a deal you have like that's a 68
in that's too big Oh God where's Walmart
there's one never see them where's that
Panama City Oh Panorama City Panama City
anymore that's one by you closer to you
somewhere really yeah one more we saw we
went to one more in Arizona and I was
like why don't we have these in LA but
they're outside of LA it go like
Cerritos are not the same neither though
like all Martinez shit they don't have
guns cuz we need guns
alright well we're really we've we've
done exhausted we're in an hour so
that's good okay this was like a pilot
episode then you guys are gonna start
having guests do yeah and no some oh
geez and yes with them so many I can't
wear the type of guess we're gonna have
to we're gonna have comedians yes miss
event weird people
we have local weirdos in our
neighborhood and we want to bring in and
talk to ya are obsessed with a pigeon
squirrel by you know the paint's on his
beard hmm other people people find
Trader Joe's and Silverlake um then
we're gonna have black people on oh and
also no black sorry sorry
101 people yes oh we should yeah yeah I
got some porn stars a he's your
boyfriend
oh great I love porn and then that Oh
her super suit we're gonna trade good
stuff gay things aggressively gay gay
bear music bands that were interested us
up Mac SF who's a bear you sit on it and
he's aggressive all the way down on it
what are you talking about web says with
Gabe Erica oh I am and I force him to be
in j-bert bears
Oh
yeah when otters we're both kind of like
we can easily give a day there and yeah
a lot of comics and funny people
it's gonna be a fun time yeah we're
gonna really have a good time with this
yeah I'm excited this is good so far you
guys you better have my donut it's a fun
trip to your mom's house yeah I hope you
had a good time at your mom's house wait
your two mommies are still here -
mommy's so in yes you guys both have
Twitter's and both have websites watch
you guys bust those out so people know
where to hit you up at yes you go first
time I'll be I'm at Tom Segura calm and
you're going to Minneapolis in a couple
weeks to do a week at Acme and look
forward to seeing you guys learn and I'm
Krystina comedy calm and I'll be in
Scottsdale Arizona this Friday and
Saturday at stand-up Scottsdale and then
at the funny farm in Georgia the second
week in December so come to see me
please I heart you can I use your
bathroom I'm gonna make PT 2 I know my
people I got a really my people stacking
shit in between your legs ok I gotta
write bright calm and see you guys later